signals of a workaround for the stimulus
bill president trump says he is ready to
sign executive orders if necessary
to tackle the growing list of issues
which have twisted democrats and his
negotiators in a knot
yet even as he accuses democrats of
holding critical relief hostage the
president says he is still looking to
reach a broad agreement
with congress all this amid new reports
from u.s intelligence officials
that hostile foreign powers are once
again trying to influence the outcome of
the upcoming election
paula reid has more from new jersey
where the president is staying at his
gulf resort
this weekend paula good morning
good morning jeff last night the
president called a sudden press
conference
where he signaled that he will take
executive action to extend relief on
student
loans on evictions and unemployment
but it's not clear the president
actually has the authority to extend
this kind of relief
that's usually left up to congress
president trump summoned reporters to
his new jersey golf club late friday
i will act under my authority as
president to get
americans the relief they need
but he hasn't signed anything yet and
dodged questions about whether he has
the constitutional authority
to go around congress to issue this
relief which he says would
delay evictions payroll taxes and
student loan payments
and extend unemployment benefits though
the amount would not be the 600 dollars
a week the democrats want
white house negotiators and top
democrats conceded friday
they're at a stalemate after two weeks
of negotiations
what they want is a two and a half
trillion dollar
blank check come back when you when you
are ready to give us a higher number but
the president is banking on an economic
recovery to propel him to re-election
yesterday the u.s intelligence community
took an unprecedented step
by publicly revealing who china and
russia favor to win in november
with top officials writing china prefers
that president trump
whom beijing sees as unpredictable does
not win reelection
china would love us to have an election
where donald trump
lost to sleepy joe biden they would
dream they would own
our country according to intelligence
officials russia
is actively trying to denigrate former
vice president biden
and what it sees as anti-russia
establishment
the russians don't want me to be the
nominee they spent a lot of money on
bots on
facebook russia preferred president
trump in 2016
according to intelligence assessments
and this year kremlin linked actors are
actively supporting his candidacy on
social media
this report also found that iran would
like to see president trump
just be a one-term president now on that
economic relief that the president has
promised
he said his lawyers are working on those
orders he could sign them at the end of
this week
that leaves open the possibility of
additional negotiations on capitol hill
or the possibility that none of this
coronavirus relief
will be extended tarika paula reed thank
you